oh my god you guys are still talking about
spider-man well they keep revealing stuff about
spider-man all right guys so we got two things we
got to talk about today first thing on the list
tom holland wants the amazing spider-man 3. talked
about why we're gonna go into the video itself in
a second and then the other thing is both him
and charlie cox spoke about this tom holland
spoke about wanting a daredevil spider-man
team-up movie i also want to kind of go into
which comic i'd like them to specifically
adapt as well or at least draw inspiration
from i feel like it would line up the
best with the mcu with that being said
let's uh hit that like button if you haven't done
it so whip it and now let's uh let's go into this
all right so first thing on the list here we got
uh tom holland talking with brandon davis from
comicbook.com the legendary man brandon davis he
is and here's where he asks him about the amazing
spider-man 3 have you seen this this clip in here
yeah no are you one of us who also want to see
the amazing spider-man 3 with andrea returning i
would love to see the amazing spider-man 3 i think
what was so wonderful was how andrew was able
to kind of make amends with the character in
the studio you know uh to kind of win the general
public back uh that scene where he saved zendaya
like the fan reactions in the theater were so
spectacular so should sony decide to do that they
would have my full support and obviously so would
andrew i mean it just makes a big difference to me
because obviously we've talked extensively about
what the amazing spider-man 3 could ultimately
be we even did a video not long ago about every
clue in easter egg that morbius and venom are
in the andrew garfield spider-man universe it's
like with tom holland going out there and showing
his support for it that just gives it an extra
push that it actually seems like it's a real
possibility giving the you know like the stamp of
approval like please go ahead and do it makes it
feel like even more like it could actually come
to fruition oh yeah especially in a post-snyder
cut world and in a world now where all the doors
are off and everyone's got a multiverse seems more
possible than ever and i think that there are more
than enough clues to indicate that it is likely to
happen maybe some sprinkling some andrew garfield
in and some of the other sony stuff and at least
and building up to it yeah i heard one theory
going around that maybe the reason why dayton
de haan's green goblin doesn't appear or wasn't
even mentioned in spiderman no way home is because
when he talks about how he let his rage get the
best of him in no way home then maybe he actually
killed one dana hans green goblin that's that's
a quite a grip but i could i could imagine it and
that would be a fascinating thing to watch that
character deal with the aftermath of all right
guys well yeah now that we got that out of the
way i hope that tom holland's endorsement allows
us to happen let's talk about some daredevil news
recently we had tom holland in the media he said
this when talking about spider-man no way home and
daredevil he said it obviously teased the future
of what could be i hope that one day we find a way
for spider-man and daredevil to team up again and
then charlie cox was actually recently asked about
this uh have you seen this yet i have not this is
all news to me all right then i'm going to play
this here and it's only like a minute long of
charlie cox talking about this and this is the
stuff i'm most excited about i mean i i i i feel
so lucky to have been cast in that role and it and
it is the gift that keeps on giving i loved every
single minute making the show but so to be honest
to come back um and to be involved in any capacity
is absolutely thrilling to me and i hope you know
i don't want to sound greedy but i hope i get to
do loads more i hope i get to be involved way way
more for many years i hope it never ends i hope
i hope it gets a point where people are
like you're too old to be playing this part
never kiana reeves it look and i i don't know
what their plans are but yes my hope is that i
get to do as much as much as i as i'm allowed
to do and to be involved and and you know be
really fun the one thing that being in the
mcu allows that we couldn't really do in the
with the netflix stuff is that i can now interact
with other mcu yeah right you can um so i'd like
that would be really cool crossovers would be
really is the thing i would like to do next i
don't know what it looks like and i don't know
what you know what they're planning and all that
kind of stuff but you know that that's there are
some really interesting stories there that i would
like to i'd love for the character to explore
well i realized i just downloaded this clip but i
didn't actually watch it how did you hear me if
i've seen it have you seen this i mean him talking
about that brings up such great points it's like
charlie cox was only able to interact with pretty
much whatever netflix characters he was allowed
to interact with you know in the comics especially
daredevil and spider-man have teamed up like many
times part of the excitement of seeing daredevil
representing peter parker in no way home which is
something that's happened in comics before where
matt murdock has represented peter parker i would
absolutely love for him to keep on going i mean
we're hearing rumors about him possibly appearing
in echo you know we're also hearing rumors about
kingpin be touted up as one of like the the next
big villains of the street level side of the mcu
perhaps for turning in the echo series what i've
kind of been hoping for personally is that in the
90s there was this comic run i believe it's called
spider-man kingpin to the death in that comic book
basically there's someone is like dressed up as
spider-man and they're you know committing crimes
that are making it seem like spider-man's doing
it daredevil doesn't believe it's him daredevil
and spider-man they end up working together and
they uncover that the man behind this plan is
actually kingpin wilson fisk with the fact that
we have kingpin reintroduced in hawkeye and then
presumably will come back in the echo series no no
that's confirmed that's just a major speculation
but let's assume he is and then if we could start
building up kingpin in the new spider-man trilogy
with tom holland where now this new peter parker
the one that where everyone's forgotten who peter
parker is he's more street level so you could
start building up kingpin so what if we can get to
a part three of the new trilogy where then you
have you know a team-up movie where you have
daredevils arch nemesis that has established in
the netflix series and then you have spider-man's
new nemesis as established in the new trilogy and
they have to team up together to take him down i
think that would be like the perfect team-up movie
especially for you know charlie cox and spider-man
i think people really want to see specifically
daredevil and spider-man work side by side oh yeah
and plus you would get the added bonus of having
them meet all over again given the spell and the
way things end in spider-man no way home like
they would get to forge a whole new relationship
after that then you could watch them you know as
you saw them in the legal setting for a second and
now you get to see them out in the street getting
physical and fighting crime and i think that would
be a really fun way to yeah pay homage to what's
come before but also start completely fresh well
there's a comic book too i don't remember the name
of it but it's one of the ones when spider-man
does have the uh symbiote suit he's like becoming
a little bit more unhinged and violent and
daredevil's trying to like reel him in kind of
of that provocation what i'm thinking that they
could do is sort of draw some inspiration from
that that if he might think that spider-man is
actually the one committing these crimes and he's
trying to take him down and then perhaps going off
of what they do with no way home he could be like
look here's who i am you got to try to remember me
you actually helped me once you know so i think
that way you like tie this all together in that
regard too would be a pretty neat way of handling
it and a great way to take out that first piece of
unraveling the spell without going straight to ned
and mj yeah yeah to try that i mean if you were
to do something where it's like you know me we've
met you know come on and like you know realize it
so i think there's a lot of really exciting
things we got the madame webb in store right now
obviously tom hall will be coming back despite
whatever [ __ ] he's saying he's coming back and
then i think with this multiverse established you
could totally have your andrew garfield universe
running simultaneously tom holland's endorsing it
they're basically all endorsing the spider-verse
so let's keep this train going guys what do
you think about this do you want daredevil
and spiderman to team up do i need to ask you this
question leave a like we will catch you guys soon